I'm from the south and I have a Southern
accent which for some people in the
north because they're stereotypically
idiots they immediately assume that
because I have a Southern accent my IQ
is lower than theirs I got rid of about
80% of my country fried redneck accent I
kept a little for flavor but um I didn't
grow up with any money so what's the
difference in me and my next door
neighbor we had the same accent and then
why am I sitting here and he's not in
terms of net worth it's oh people like
us we can't get ahead Thank God It's
Friday oh God it's got your hope the
president fixes my life it's a victim
mentality that causes you to not take
action you have to plant something if
you want something to grow I've been
rich and I've been broke but I've never
been poor poor is a state of mind